Charleston virginia's police chief is
not admitting any failures in the way
his department responded to saturday's
violent protests but he says he regrets
the loss of life 32 year-old Heather
hire was killed when a car was used to
attack a group of counter demonstrators
and to Virginia state troopers died
monitoring the protests lieutenant HJ
Cullen and trooper pilot Burk Bates were
killed when their helicopter crashed
David Beck no is outside the City Hall
in Charlottesville David good morning
charlie good morning outside City Hall
here is a writing wall this wasn't free
speech this was terrorism and resigned
City Council we asked a lot of pointed
questions of the police chief yesterday
who told us that of the thousand
officers who were in this area he told
his men to show up in their regular
uniform and he was also questioned about
an allegation that someone within his
department told his men to stand down
when things got violent the chief said
that is absolutely not true
it was a challenge it was certainly a
challenge chief al Thomas jr. says it
took about an hour to regain control of
the streets in downtown Charlottesville
on Saturday and you would ret not having
your officers better prepared and in
their proper gear earlier so they could
have acted sooner absolutely I have
regrets and what are your regrets
we lost three lives but I'm just I'm
talking about the actions of North Park
I certainly have regrets
chief Thomas said the security plan
called for the white supremacists and
counter protesters to enter Emancipation
Park through separate entrances
but when the white supremacist who the
chief says agreed to the plan started
using other entrances skirmishes broke
out around 11:30 a.m. police began to
clear the park of all demonstrators
sending them out into the streets
we had the groups that were moving
constantly we were following a number of
groups ensuring that they were being
peaceful we were spread thin once the
groups dispersed about two hours after
police ordered the park vacated James
Alex fields jr. a white supremacist from
Ohio allegedly rammed his Dodge
Challenger into a group of counter
protesters Heather hire was killed at
least 19 other people were hurt on
Monday the 20 year old security guard
was denied bond he's being held on
second degree murder and other charges
after the hearing he was fired from his
security job outside of court white
nationalist tried to absolve fields of
any blame this is on the city government
of the police and the radical left this
morning police are looking into the
background and electronic records of
that man who drove his car into that
crowd of people trying to figure out
that he have help or did anybody direct
him to do what he did Gail there are
court records in Kentucky when that
young man was 12 years old his mother
who's in a wheelchair by the way
apparently threatened him with a knife
threatened her with a knife locked her
in a bathroom and hit her in the head
boy David what kind of person do you
have to be to threaten your mother not
alone your disabled mother thank you
very much